derniers préparatifs avant le grand
départ grâce au module évasion reginaldo
s'apprête à se balader en pleine nature
dans son propre fauteuil électrique sans
permet de découvrir la nature est un
acteur mode de vision un peu partout à
tous à tous nos bulles d'une colline au
labo tout partout partout cette
cinquième édition du rallye découverte à
la base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines permet aux personnes à mobilité
réduite de s'essayer à de nouvelles
activités
il faut un peu considérés comme des
personnes à part entière alors que
souvent on les regarde de travers là ils
sont accueillis donc c'est vraiment une
chance extraordinaire
et donc ils sont comme tout le monde et
lors de cette journée valides et
handicapés se mélangent quand on se
rencontre et qu'on se connaît il ya des
chances que le contact face et qu'on se
regarde différemment si pour ça qu'on a
envie de montrer qu'on est là pour tous
pour la famille pour les jeunes les
personnes âgées et ceux qui ont mobilité
réduite
ceux qui sont valides et tous ensemble
eh ben on s'active pour promouvoir
la diversité la mule et multi talents et
c'est stéphane accompagnée de sa fille
victoire a laissé son fauteuil roulant
pour un siège tout terrain est là avec
son fauteuil tout terrain on peut se
promener dans l'herbe dans la terrible
côte un peu partout dans la boue gas
exactement et puis ça permet d'essayer
du matériel qu'on peut pas avoir
personnellement et ça permet de se
promener en toute liberté ses fers pour
la dixième semaine du handicap ces
activités sont proposées jusqu'à
vendredi
au programme tir à l'arc calèche ou
encore grimpe à l'arbre